-Republicans and right
wing pundits
who support Donald Trump
have spent the last few days
pretending to be outraged
over a hot mic moment
in which President Biden
insulted a Fox News reporter.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
Today, we're going to discuss
Republican reactions to Biden
calling a Fox News reporter
a stupid S.O.B. on a hot mic
because I'm willing to bet
anything that's going to be
the biggest story in politics
for the foreseeable future.
-This is a
CBS News Special Report
I'm Major Garrett in Washington.
There is breaking news
from the Supreme Court.
CBS News has learned
Justice Stephen Breyer plans
to retire at the end
of this term in June.
-Oh, Seth, you stupid
son of a bitch.
Pulled a Biden on myself. Well,
at least it works as a segue.
News of Justice Breyer's
retirement
broke just a few hours
before this taping,
so I'll have more to say
about it tomorrow.
But this afternoon,
Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer said Democrats
would confirm a successor
with all deliberate speed.
And I can understand why you'd
want to have someone in place
before Republicans
win back Congress
because as GOP reaction
to Biden's hot mic moment
has once again proved,
in order to be
a Trump supporter,
you have to lobotomize
the part of your brain
responsible for shame.
That's why Rudy Giuliani
always looks like
he just woke up
midbrain surgery.
Is this a still from
the new "Matrix" movie?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ] I took the
red pill and the blue pill,
and I got to say, still nothing
happening downstairs.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] By the way,
we've used that picture
so many times it's gotten a
little dusty, hold on.
And that's it.
Not even February.
It's our entire special effects
budget for the year.
For example, here's Trump's son,
Eric, on Fox News last night
claiming Trump worked harder
than the current administration.
-These people aren't present,
they're not fighting
for this country.
You know the difference
between them and my father.
My father sat there
24 hours a day
and fought for the
United States' best interests.
-Well, the "sat there"
part of your sentence
was the only part
that was true.
Trump definitely sat there.
He was the king of sitting.
He always had that posture like
a retired major league catcher
whose body just froze like that.
He did that upside down
diamond thing with his hands
like Bizarro World Jay-Z.
Trump's political superpower
was his lack of shame.
There was no crime
he wouldn't commit.
No lie, he wouldn't tell,
no matter how obvious
or brazen it was.
Trump would have walked
out of the White House
with the bust of Abraham Lincoln
sticking out of his coat pocket,
if he thought
he'd get away with it,
Which he might've been able to
do since his coat looked like
it was specifically made
to hide marble busts.
What was that conversation
like with his tailor?
[ Italian accent ]
Look at these beautiful lines,
we can put a Lincoln right here
a Washington right here,
no one will know.
[ As Trump ] You've done it
again, Giuseppe.
You've done it again.
[ Normal voice ]
And in order to support him,
Trump's backers had to find ways
to convince us that they
didn't know he was the con man
he obviously was.
Like the way Republican
lawmakers
would always have conveniently
not read his tweets.
Or the way they kept insisting
he learned his lessons.
They said this man
learned his lesson.
He didn't even learn
not to hit the tweet button.
If there was a red dotted line
under a word.
He would just say, "I'm pretty
sure "tap" does have two P's.
And on this Twitter,
we're just going to have
to agree to disagree."
I mean, forget Donald Trump.
In the history of this nation,
no rich white man,
in his '70s,
has ever learned his lesson.
The only thing rich white men
learn is salsa dancing,
and that's only if
their third wife insists on it.
[ Laughter ]
So in order to say
something as naive
as "Trump learned his lesson,"
you have to have numbed
the part of your brain
that cares if people think
you look stupid,
that's clearly what's going on
in the latest fake controversy
surrounding Biden's outburst
that Fox News correspondent
Peter Doocy,
which I'm sure
you've all seen by now.
But here it is anyway, just for
us all to enjoy one more time.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Biden was muttering to himself
like he just got cut off
on the interstate
in his stingray,
[ As Biden ] "Look at his stupid
son of a bitch.
No, go ahead and merge.
Definitely don't signal
or check your mirrors.
You're the only person
in the whole damn world,
baby on board. Good luck.
Growing up, normal kid."
[ Normal voice ]
Now Biden's 79, okay?
Have you guys ever seen
two old guys greet each other?
"Hey, look at his old son
of a bitch."
"Hey, Bert, you [Bleep] I see
you're still ugly as sin."
It's honestly pretty sweet,
but word of warning
you can jump in on that
if you're under 60,
they don't like that.
"Hey, grandpa, you old bastard."
"What the hell did you say to
me, you little turd?!"
And look, ideally, the president
would not lob insults
at anyone, including reporters.
But if we're being honest,
you know?
It was kind of
a stupid question.
I mean, really,
does Biden think inflation
is a political liability?
What's he supposed to say?
"No. No.
I think it's good that gas and
ground beef are more expensive.
I'm going to cruise
to reelection
on the strength of Subway's
$6 foot long."
Anyway, all in all, I do have to
say both Doocy and Biden
have handled this incident well.
Doocy laughed it off,
said he wasn't owed an apology,
and Biden called him
to tell him,
"It's nothing personal, pal,"
which does strike me
as kind
of a non-apology apology.
You called him
a stupid son of a bitch.
If it wasn't personal,
then what was it, business?
[ Laughter ]
That's how we seal
the deal in Scranton.
You agree to the term
shake hands,
look each other in the eye
and say,
"You stupid son of a bitch."
[ Laughter ]
But let's just get the false
equivalency out of the way.
No, this isn't even
remotely like Trump,
who repeatedly whipped
his crazed fans
into a frenzy
by hurling insults at reporters
and calling them
the enemy of the people.
Calling one person an S.O.B.
and then apologizing for it
is not the same
as unrepentantly hurling
a constant stream
of verbal abuse of reporters
and threatening to punish
or imprison them
or change
the laws to target them.
I could give countless
examples of this,
but here's just one random one
I happen to like.
When Trump called a reporter
a criminal in 2020
for not reporting
on his deranged conspiracy
theories about the Biden family
during the election.
-He is a criminal.
He's a criminal.
He got caught.
Read his laptop.
And you know who's a criminal?
You're a criminal
for not reporting it.
You are a criminal
Let me tell you something.
Joe Biden is a criminal
and he's been a criminal
for a long time
and you're a criminal
and the media
for not reporting it.
Good luck.
Everybody have a good time.
Now, you can't tell them
to have a good time
after you call them criminals.
The only way that works
is you're at the Legion
of Doom Christmas party.
[ As Lex Luthor ] This is the
largest gathering of criminals,
lowlife, and evil villains
the world has ever known.
Have a good time.
Don't forget to put your Secret
Santa gifts
on the table
by the alligator pit.
[ Normal voice ]
That was always Trump's way of
just erasing everything
he said right before it.
"Have a good time."
Like he'd be in
the middle of a terrifying rant
where he threatens nuclear
annihilation with North Korea.
And then he'd wrap it up
by saying,
"So, if we have to burn this guy
and turn the world to ash,
I will summon God's vengeance
and rain blood
down upon my enemies.
But for now,
you have a good time."
You know, because he'd be in the
middle of a wedding toast
at Mar-a-Lago.
You may now kiss the bride,
before she's a pile of ash.
So Trump's record on this
is obvious
to anyone who's been awake
for the last few years.
And yet there still
some Republicans
who think we were all born
within the last 12 months
and have no memory of what Trump
was like as president.
For example,
Indiana Congressman Jim Banks
tweeted in total sincerity,
not as a joke.
"Have we ever seen a president
attack and malign
the free press
like Joe Biden has?"
Only one or two things
can be happening here,
either he's trolling us
because Trump's record
of antagonism toward the press
is so obvious
that he knows a comment
like that will drive
the rest of us insane.
Or he's got some sort of
Benjamin Button disease
where he looks like
a middle aged man,
but was actually born
like a few months ago
and legitimately doesn't know
who Donald Trump is.
And if that's the case,
good on him.
I mean, if congressman
Banks really is a baby
who looks like a full grown man
who am I to [Bleep] all over him
for being dumb
as a bag of rocks?
I have a baby at home.
She didn't do anything.
But this baby
is out here not letting
Benjamin Button disease
slow him down,
serving his constituents.
Go to work every day
with people who all
have faces
that are terrifying to babies.
He's going to talk
to these people,
and I burst into tears, probably
as a full diaper half the day.
So again, if Congressman Banks
is a Benjamin Button situation,
and that's why he doesn't
remember how Donald Trump
treated the press, I apologize.
But you know, if he is just a
regular 42-year-old man,
you know, shut the [Bleep] up.
But that was somehow not,
that was somehow not
the most disingenuous reaction
from a Republican
member of Congress.
There was also Ronny Jackson,
Trump's former doctor, who
claimed in 2018,
that Trump aced
the cognitive test.
Jackson said on
Fox News yesterday
that Biden's hot mic moment
was a sign of cognitive decline.
-It's completely unprofessional.
It's embarrassing.
And I've seen
this multiple times
with people
at the president's age
that are starting to have
cognitive issues.
They get short tempered, they
get irritable, they strike out.
It's a defense mechanism to some
extent when they don't know
exactly how to answer questions
or what's going on around them.
He's got cognitive issues.
He's not fit to be our head --
head of state
or our commander in chief.
-Now, yes, he's a doctor,
but remember,
he's a doctor
whose name is Ronny.
Now, do you have
your medical degree?
You sure you don't want to
change it to Ronald?
"Nah, nah. I want people to know
what they're getting
when they walk in the door.
[ Light laughter ]
Dr. Ronny.
[ Normal voice ]
But let me see if I follow --
short temper, irritable,
striking out
as a defense mechanism
when they don't know
how to answer questions
doesn't know what's going
on around them.
I just wish there was an example
of someone prominent
with those symptoms
who we could compare him to.
It's just stumping me.
I mean, for the life of me,
I can't think of anyone
who's ever exhibited
these specific personality
traits before.
I mean, certainly not someone
in the public eye,
someone we all remember,
you know, a businessman
or elected official,
perhaps someone who served in
a high profile position within,
I don't know, let's say,
the last 13 months,
if only that person existed?
Well,
I guess we'll never know.
This is one of those
seemingly trivial moments
that actually reveals
something fundamental
at the heart
of modern Republican politics.
In order to be
a successful Republican today,
you simply have
to have no shame,
which is why it's understandable
the Democrats want to move
as quickly as possible
to confirm a successor
for Justice Breyer
before Republicans
have a chance to win
back the Senate in November
because if Mitch McConnell
and the GOP get their way,
they'll hold this seat hostage
until a Republican president
can appoint someone
they like someone who's a --
-Short tempered, irritable.
-Stupid son of a bitch.
This has been "A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over two million
meals a year to men,
women, and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.